des témoins qui ont également révélé la
face cachée du financement politique
monsieur le premier ministre c'est
certain monsieur le président que si des
contributions des fêtes façon illégale
et démontrer comme tel le remboursement
se fait plus rien de nouveau là-dedans
c'est le cas le premier ministre ne veut
pas rembourser l'argent qui a été
collecté avant 2010 par le parti libéral
de façon illégale
honte à lui
le deuxième groupe d'opposition faites
attention à vos propos on s'attendait à
ce que la sortie du rapport de la
commission charbonneau fasse de plus
grosses vagues tous ces témoignages ces
documents et on en arrive où il ya de
nombreuses recommandations mais aussi à
une conclusion mitigé alors est-ce que
l'exercice en aura valu la peine
daniel tâche à michel bonsoir à vous
trois michel je vais commencer avec vous
parce que j'aimerais qu'on fasse un
petit tour avant juste sur la mise à
jour économique
un petit tour de table rapide donc un
léger surplus de l'argent réinvesti en
est en éducation est ce que ça veut dire
que les compressions s'est terminée au
nom il faudrait surtout pas croire ça
monsieur l'état a voulu je pense donner
le signal qu'ils avaient un peu de
lumière au bout du tunnel avec les 100
millions qui est annoncée pour
l'éducation mais gérald bien et qui est
tantôt ça demeure des augmentations de
dépenses au total qui sont bien en deçà
de l'inflation et ça va continuer comme
ça même si on continue à générer des
surplus au cours des prochaines années
le premier skieur était très clair les
surplus vont aller pour moitié dans la
réduction de la dette et pour l'autre
moitié dans la diminution du fardeau
fiscal des contribuables alors il va
falloir s'habituer à un niveau de
dépenses qui vont être beaucoup moins
d'augmentation des dépenses devrait dire
qu'il va être beaucoup moins important
que ce à quoi on avait été habitué par
les années passées le résultat de tout
ça c'est que ce qu'on appelle les coûts
de système c'est à dire l'argent dont on
a besoin pour maintenir les services au
même niveau ne sera pas là alors il
normalement on devrait ajuster les
budgets en fonction des besoins mais là
c'est les besoins qui vont devoir se
satisfaire des budgets qu'on a fixés
daniel ont réinvesti quand même en
éducation quel message le gouvernement
voit je pense que c'est purement
symbolique quelques millions $ sur un
budget total de 17 milliards de dollars
ça va pas changer grand grand chose sur
le fond à le message il est là ça
permettra au gouvernement de dire non
c'est pas vrai qu'on ne s'occupe pas de
l'éducation parce que c'est peut-être
l'élément ne plus le plus ancien c'est
peut-être ce qui fait le plus mal au
bout
ornements on a vu la fin de semaine
dernière un sondage qui pour une très
très très rare fois nous dit qu'ils nous
disaient que ball à la majorité des
québécois pas une grosse majorité mais
une majorité étaient d'accord avec les
revendications des enseignants des
employés du domaine de la santé donc il
ya un mécontentement très grand surtout
dans le domaine de l'éducation
car les enseignants sont mécontents les
étudiants sont mécontents les parents
sont mécontents il ya un climat qui est
pas très très agréable en ce moment je
pense que ça le gouvernement couillard
sans pouvoir de corriger complètement
avait envoyé un message qui se
préoccupent de l'éducation mais ça reste
purement symbolique achats mise à jour
économique aussi en l'ontario la
situation est plus difficile mais là
aussi à deux il ya du mécontentement
oui justement je veux pas rire de ça
mais si la province vient de conclure
des ententes cet automne avec les
enseignants les syndicats des
enseignants justement sont accusés
d'avoir trop donner justement dans ce
budget ici on voit que vont légèrement
il ya des augmentations de revenus
comparativement à ce qu'on attendait
pour l'interview mais c'est toujours en
déficit pour équilibrer le budget d'ici
2018 qui est le but de l'exercice
on dit que le gouvernement se replie sur
les fonds qui sont générés par la vente
d'actions dont hydro 1 c'est notre comme
hydro québec ciq
et c'est quelque chose d' écoute le
gouvernant nyx com et tout le monde sait
que autrement il n'aurait pas atteint
l'objectif budgétaire mais pour cette
année mais 300 milliards de dollars de
dette vont être accomplies par l'ontario
d'ici l'année prochaine c'est effrayant
mais la situation est difficile pour
nous serait très difficile et le secteur
manufacturier en ontario est en panne et
honnêtement c'est un grave
l'économie ne va pas très bien si on dit
alberto va pas bien mais sa bopp bien
antérieurs non plus bon alors passons à
ce rapport la commission charbonneau
rapport très attendu mais qui en a
laissé plusieurs sur leur appétit
daniel pour vous est-ce que ça en a valu
la peine quand même
choses qui ont changé pendant la
commission en fait oui le travail de
sape avait été fait fort bien faire par
nos collègues journalistes d' enquête de
la presse et du devoir et finalement
jean charest avait avait avait avait mis
sur pied cette comité cette commission
en lui donnant un mandat beaucoup de
roulage en nommant des gens qui étaient
peut-être pas prêt à faire ce genre de
travail là ils sont souvent allés à la
pêche rappelez vous la liste d'un club
privé de montréal de personnalités
connues
rappelez vous cet épisode pas très
glorieux duchesneau a cure saut bref on
avait l'impression qu'ils savaient
patrouille à l'aise à la commission
gomery des premiers ministres un
chrétien martin avait témoigné pas
devant cette commission
on a l'impression que il ya des choses
qui manquaient dans tout ça est-ce que
ça a été inutile non est-ce que ça a été
utile oui il ya toujours ce pédagogie là
dessus les gens contre il y avait un
sérieux problème de corruption
elle sert à quoi et si des bons avec le
départ de gilles vaillancourt à laval de
gerald tremblay à montréal
ça n'a pas été complètement inutile mais
les gens qui sont déçus obtenu raison
d'être déçu des résultats de la fin qui
scelle oui ben moi je pense que quand
même une utilité une utilité réelle dans
la mesure où de la simple fait que la
commission s'est mis à enquêter sur un
peu partout à tout le monde c'est un peu
autodiscipline et on a vu que bien avant
que le rapport soit soit remis on avait
vu les extras diminuer beaucoup dans les
contrats publics
on a vu les
les syndicats faire le ménage à la ftq
construction au fonds solidarité la
classe politique aussi singulièrement
modifié les modes de financement des
partis maintenant c'est essentiellement
l'état qui équipaient les dépenses ça
rend le besoin de d'argent qui est à la
base de toute cette histoire là de
contrats octroyés en retour de chris
eaton ce tout ça va être beaucoup moins
évident à l'avenir alors il ya eu cette
utilité là mais évidemment je comprends
pourquoi les gens restent sur leur faim
parce que le rapport lui même ce qui
était au coeur du rapport s'est finie en
queue de poisson mais le financement des
partis politiques est d'offrir des
contrats d'achat mais je pense qu'un
nettoyage convient de dire dans le sens
de départ de ces mères le fait que les
gens se sont retenus dix ont peut-être
de faire de mauvaises choses parce
qu'ils savaient qu'il y avait une
certaine lumière qui était mise sur la
situation mais je pense dans la fin de
la journée oui à une grande déception
parce que vraiment il ya des divisions
dans le rapport et deuxièmement c'est
pas clair c'est indirect le lien qui a
été trouvée alors on accuse monsieur
péladeau accuse d'asséner
d'assainissement du rapport un
blanchissement dans un sens
est ce que c'est le cas on saurait
jamais mais c'est sûr que les attentes
je pense ne sont les attentes étaient
beaucoup plus élevés que leurs résultats
et les recommandations sinon plus
écoutée dire que on va on va dire pour
qui les personnes travailler pendant
qu'ils donnaient des sommes aux partis
politiques
je pense pas que ça va changer le fait
s'il ya des gens qui veulent contourner
la loi ils vont faire quand même
bon évidemment ce qu'ont à vous en avez
vous l'avez évoqué d'achat mais ce qu'on
a beaucoup retenu c'est la dissension
dans ce rapport le commissaire renaud
lachance qui refusent de voir le lien
direct ou indirect entre le financement
des partis politiques et l'octroi des
contrats
michel ça vient discréditer le rapport
ah ben ça lui a salué enlève à peu près
tout son mordant qui ait pas de lien
direct c'était difficile à établir au
niveau provincial ça a été facile au
niveau municipal de monsieur 3 % sur
chaque contre bon ça stackler mai
au niveau provincial et à beaucoup un
éclair mais quand vous avez des gens qui
viennent témoigner devant la commission
qui vous expliquent que les solliciteurs
de fonds vont voir les entreprises
ils disent voyez tous les contrats que
vous avez obtenu là il faudrait
peut-être renvoyer l'ascenseur et si ça
s'appelle pas un lien direct entre le
financement des partis et l'octroi de
contrats je sais pas ce que c'est la
juge a pas dit et peut aller jusqu'à
dire qu'il y avait un lien direct
mais elle a dit ça me semble tellement
évident qu'ils avaient un lien direct et
c'est ce lien même indirect que que
monsieur lachance a refusé de voir
j'avoue que je comprends c'est mal mais
le résultat c'est que fait du mal le
rapport est il très mou dans ses
conclusions oui non et on a on a souvent
l'impression que ces commissions dans
lequel ça va tout régler ces commission
d' enquête vise avant tout à apaiser la
population qui en a assez de telle ou
telle situation il y en a eu une
magistrale sur les autochtones erasmus
du saut avec des recommandations pour
couvrir à peu près tous les problèmes
qu'ils avaient et aujourd'hui encore
cela n'a pas empêché les vador de ce
monde et ça n'a rien réglé si bien que
la semaine prochaine on va l'annoncer
une autre commission d' enquête sur les
femmes autochtones disparues
alors ce n'est pas la panacée loin de là
c'est utile michel réseau sa force les
gens à faire attention un peu plus il
s'agira de voir si ça va durer
mais ça ne règle pas les problèmes mais
celle là encore moi parce que la
conclusion il faut l'admettre et à ces
désordres
bon ça a été une grosse semaine en
actualité le gouvernement trudeau a
finalement décidé de ralentir la cadence
sur le plan des réfugiés dont vingt-cinq
mille réfugiés mais d'ici la fin février
seulement donc il s'est ravisé justin
trudeau tasha c'était la bonne chose à
faire
absolument a coûté de la population lui
disais ça
les l'opposition lui disais ça et je
pense probablement aussi je sais pas
être directement mais les chefs des
autres pays qu'il a rencontré
probablement avec l'association à paris
je ne serais pas surpris s'il aurait dit
attendez caution parce que effectivement
si son plan aurait permis à la rentrée
d'un terroriste par exemple dans tout ce
processus
il aurait payé un énorme prix politique
alors mieux faire que ça n'arrive pas
qui a pas aussi de backlash comme on
dirait dans parmi les canadiens si le
processus de tourner au vinaigre s'il le
rétablissement de ces gens le voient pas
de façon très bien organisée alors je
pense qu'il a fait là la bonne décision
de ramener ces gens sur un canapé plus
long et aussi de faire la sélection à
l'extérieur du canada au lieu dit si
c'était une promesse fort quand même de
justin trudeau c'était quelque chose
il y tenait beaucoup jusqu'à la fin il
là il a gardé le cap et puis finalement
cette décision il
il a eu l'intelligence de 2,2 de
s'adapter à la situation qui n'est pas
une situation difficile si on peut lui
faire un reproche c'est peut-être
d'avoir pris la bouche un peu trop
grosse moins dans la campagne électorale
s'ils venaient à plus vous savez se
traînait les pieds parlait de quelques
centaines à quelques milliers à le npd
étaient la dime et de rapidement justin
trudeau à 25000 y avait une espèce de
surenchère
c'était sans compter tous les problèmes
que ça pose vous disiez tout à l'heure
on a donné que 928 visant à aux gens qui
vont venir au canada ça s'est donnée par
le liban par la jordanie
ça se fait d'une lenteur extrême si bien
que les 10000 avant noël pote par la
faute du canada mais par la faute de ces
pays là pourraient ne pas se réaliser
donc c'est un dossier très compliqué sa
tête était l'erreur d'assaut l'erreur de
trop nous en campagne électorale et il
était de bonne foi ce moment là savaient
pas qu'il se passerait ce qui s'est
passé à paris mais il a bouché des
trayons michel jarre en fait je le fait
d'avoir poussé tout le monde dans ce
dossier là ça peut être un peu accéléré
les choses quand même le processus mais
c'était la bonne décision michel wiba
absolument ben vous savez promesse que
tout le monde vous demande de ne pas
tenir à paris
ou bien au contraire et daniel a raison
je pense que monsieur trudeau a lâché
son chiffre un peu en l'air comme ça
durant la campagne sans avoir des
implications
est ce qu'il ya aussi c'est que bon le
gouvernement fédéral va ramener ces gens
là va les faire les contrôles et sur le
plan de la sécurité de la santé mais
après ça c'est pas lui qui va s'en
occuper il sincèrement des provinces les
municipalités les organismes d'accueil
tous ces gens là avaient besoin d'être
consultés de se concerter et ça ça se
prend pas là en fait pas en criant
ciseau
alors il le diable est dans les détails
et dans une opération comme celle là il
y en a beaucoup de détails
oui mais quand même y annonçant une
mobilisation à travers à travers le pays
dans toutes les provinces en tout cas
municipalité et je pense qu'elle va être
elle va durer d'autant d'autant plus que
les choses vont bien se passer parce
qu'il faut jamais oublier que c'est pas
lui c'est seulement la première vague
laquelle on assiste actuellement
enfin si on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler parce que c'est une opération
de très grande envergure l'envergure en
fête qui commence
merci beaucoup à vous trois